[Musique]
après l'abandon du projet d'aéroport de
notame des land en 2018 l'État s'est
engagé en 2019 à imaginer le devenir de
l'aéroport de Nantes qui nécessite
évidemment de nombreux réaménagements
dans la mesure où pendant près de 40 ans
peu d'investissements ont été réalisés
dans la mesure où tout le monde imagine
que l'aéroport allait être
délocalisé et donc ça nécessite
aujourd'hui la prise en compte des
besoins qui sont importants pour cet
aéroport avec une croissance accrue du
nombre de passagers et de
[Musique]
vols globalement on a à la fois bien sûr
les questions d'accueil du public que ce
soit pour des départs ou des arrivées
ici à aéroport donc ça je dirais que
c'est lié à l'infrastructure en tant que
tel et puis ensuite le deuxième volet
qui est à mon sens l'un des plus
importants qui avait justifié à l'époque
le transfert de l'aéroport c'est le
survol de la ville de lantes avec tous
les effets indu et notamment en terme de
bruit effet on peut plus utiliser nos
jardins l'été ça passe toutes les 3
minutes on peut plus parler on a essayé
de vendre on perd 10 % du prix de vente
parce que com on
est n est survolé à longueur de journée
par des av donc on peut comprendre les
attentes et les exaspérations des
riverins sur le
[Musique]
sujet on a réalisé déjà un certain
nombre d'auditions de rencontres qui
devrait nous permettre de d'y voir un
peu plus clair et surtout de mesurer les
efforts à réalisés dans les années qui
viennent